So there's a point to be made. If you, I
understand you want a healthy, like you,
you want Twitter to grow,
you need it to grow.
The shareholders needed to grow
that advertisers need to advertise.
So you've got all these restrictions,
but allowing people to
say these awful things,
make sure we stay away from them and
it allows us to avoid certain people.
And it isn't an important to know
that these people hold these beliefs.
If you get rid of him,
you know,
someone could walk into a business and
you wouldn't even know that they were in
Neo Nazi, but if they were high profile
saying there things, you'd be like,
that's the guy at home.
Like you're absolutely right.
This is like one of my favorite
sayings is that sunlight is the best
disinfectant and it's so, so, so true.
I like one of the biggest problems with
censorship is the fact that you pushed
people underground and you
don't know what's going on.
And this is something I worry about.
It's not that I don't worry if
you ban people for these roles.
I also worry about driving people away
from the platform and affecting their
real lives.
So what we're trying to find this right
balance and I hear you like you may not
think we're drawing the lines in the
right place and we get that feedback all
the time and we're always
trying to find the right places.
But I worry as much about like the
underground and like being able to shine a
light on these things is as anything else.
I think it's a cost benefit analysis and
we have to constantly rehash it and do
it.
Like we,
we have the technology we have today
and we are looking at technologies which
opened up the aperture even more and we
all agree that a binary on or off is not
the right answer and is not scalable.
We have started getting into nuance
within our enforcement and we've also
started getting into nuance with
the presentation of, of content.
So you know,
one path might have been for some of
your replies for us to just remove that,
those, you know, offensive replies
completely. We don't do that.
We hide it behind an interstitual
to protect the original tweeter and,
and, and also folks who don't want to
see that they can still see everything.
They just have to do one more top.
So that's one solution.
Ranking is another solution,
but as technology gets better and
we get better at applying to it,
we have a lot more
optionality whereas we don't,
we don't have that as much today.
I feel like, I'm just going to reiterate
an earlier point though, you know,
if you recognize sunlight is the best
disinfectant, you're, it's like you're,
you're chasing after a goal that
can never be met. If you wanna.
If you want to protect all speech and
they start banning certain individual,
you want to, you want to increase
the amount of healthy conversations,
but you're banning some people.
Well,
how long until this group
is now funded by that group?
How long until you've banned everybody?
I hear you.
I don't believe a permanent ban promotes
health. I don't believe that. But we,
we have to, we have to work
with the technologies, tools
and conditions that we,
that we have today.
So and evolve over over time
to where we can see examples.
Um, like, uh,
this woman at the Westboro Baptist Church
who was using Twitter every single day
to spread hate against
the Lgbtqa community.
And over time we had,
I think it was three or four folks on
Twitter who would engage her every single
day about what she was doing. And she
actually left the church, Michael Phelps.
She's amazing. And she is, she's not
pulling her family out of that as well.
And you could make the argument that
if we banned that account early on,
she would have never left the church. I
completely hear that. We, we get it. It's,
it's just,
well, so let's, let's, I just
want to make sure we had,
we're advancing the conversation too
and not just going to go back. So, uh,
I'll just ask you this.
Have you considered allowing some of
these people permanently banned it back on
with some restrictions?
Maybe you can only tweet twice per day,
maybe you can't retweet or
something to that effect.
I think we're very early in
our thinking here. So we're,
we're open minded to how to do this.
I think we agree philosophically that
permanent bans aren't extreme case
scenario and it shouldn't be one of our,
you know,
regular use tools in our tool chest.
So how we do that I think is something
that we're actively talking about today.
Is there a timeline that we can so,
so look in all loving dad would fix
a lot of problems. I think so, yes.
I really do.
Like,
I'm just curious like are you thinking
like bands of a year or five years,
10 years?
I'm just curious like what is,
what is a reasonable ban
in this kind of context?
I think reasonably so much enough to
state their case as to why they want to be
unbanned. Like someone should have to
have a like, um, uh, well measured,
considerate response to
what they did wrong. Did,
do they agree with what they did wrong?
Maybe perhaps saying why they don't think
they did anything wrong and you could
review it from there. Hmm. I think,
um, you know, one of the challenges,
we have the benefit in English common
law of hundreds of years of precedent and
developing new rules and figuring
out what works and doesn't,
Twitter is very different.
So I think with the technology,
I don't know if you need permanent bans
or even, or even suspensions at all,
you could literally just, uh, I mean,
lock someone's account is essentially
suspending them. But, uh, I, I again, I,
I wouldn't claim to know anything
about the things that you go through,
but what if you just restricted most
of what they could say? You know,
you blocked certain words in a
certain dictionary. If someone's been,
if someone was greased hill, oh, but no,
but, but, but the thing about it this way,
is it better that they're permanently
banned or sound better, but it's not,
it's not good.
I don't know to think about it this way.
Instead of being suspended for 72 hours,
you get a dictionary block
from paid speech words.
Right.
That makes sense.
If people just use kind of language,
this is what we see all
the time. Yeah. Good move.